jamais le centre nautique de mâcon avait
connu en effet dans l'affluence puisque
430 rameurs réunis en battu le record de
participation en championnat de france
juniors 2 sans barreur six équipes
étaient au départ dans nos équipes
régionales de lyon chalon et ex le
favori pourtant les angevins s'installer
en tête dès les premiers mètres suivre
id frères véricel vraiment à 36 coups
minute les aixois biche et des côtes
hurwitz fait de remonter d'augmenter
leur avance est de gagner nettement
alors que les lyonnais s'octroyait une
troisième place méritée pour biche et
des côtes c'était une belle médaille
qu'ils avaient déjà failli remporter en
1966 autre sujet de satisfaction le
quatre barré seniors content pour
l'attribution de la coupe blanc d'azé
qui comptait deux équipes régionales
aix les bains et hans dès le départ
l'équipe aixoise composé de villars
frison varon nicolas et à stoos installé
tentes est augmentée progressivement son
avance alors que derrière la bataille
faisait rage trois équipes étant sur la
même ligne
spectateur averti le député maire
monsieur escande suivait comme le public
avec beaucoup d'intérêt cette course
indécise qui permettait à l'entente
d'aix les bains de remporter cette coupe
devant la basse seine alors que les
quatre autres équipes arrivées dans un
mouchoir
présent vers l'entente d'aix les bains
les cependant se faire accrocher dans le
cas de barricader comptant pour les
critériums nationaux
ramant à 38 coups minute laval
s'installer en tête menacée par besançon
alors que les rouennais en quatrième
position ne semblait pas émettre de
grandes prétentions la lutte devait être
merveilleuse dans les derniers mètres et
nos aixois troisième erwan et 5e
s'incliner de fort peu derrière laval
premier et besançon second mais cette
journée aura permis avant tout à
l'aviron de la région rhône-alpes de
démontrer sa belle valeur d'antan